oui bon maintenant situation critique
dans les hôpitaux des établissements
menacés par une pénurie de courant alors
que le secteur de la santé est en plein
combat contre la pandémie de kovy 19è
dans un contexte de crise économique les
hôpitaux du liban on redoute une
catastrophe sanitaire puisque la
compagnie nationale d'électricité à
cesser de fournir du courant ces
dernières semaines pour en parler nous
sommes avec angie abi rached chef du s
service de réanimation cardiaque est
directeur médical au à l'hôpital
libanais et gates a oui bonjour merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt
france alors d'abord faites nous un état
des lieux de la situation actuellement
au liban
bonjour et merci de recevoir avec vous a
lancé m en un mot la situation au liban
dans le secteur sanitaire est
catastrophique
et le pire c'est que le risque de
s'aggraver
nous sommes arrivés à un point où il
faut pas mentionné la dame au plus vite
la suite est la solution car non
seulement le système médical le système
de santé par des infirmières le la
baisse des quantités de médicaments sur
le marché
mais non le système encore plus
affaiblie par la logistique
le dl l'électricité du liban lui fournit
plus de l'électricité par défaillance
est fournie à peine deux heures entre 2h
et 4h par jour ce qui laisse les sortez
les hôpitaux alarcon chaque hôpital
chaque assistons à son générateur
d'électricité mais non encore aux morts
de carburant mort de pius de mazout de
diesel et la situation dans plusieurs
centres hospitaliers aux dépens de
carburant ce qui met en jeu
des patients toute la logistique y
assure les fonctions vitales dans les
hôpitaux risquent d'être perturbés il ya
des institutions qui risque de sonner
l'alarmé
et s'il n'y a pas de solution
tout le système risque de s'écrouler
najibi rachète vous le disais un vous
lisiez l'instant manque de un nombre de
médicaments manquent de personnel et
manque maintenant d'électricité encore
combien de temps
l'hôpital libanais peut tenir c'est une
question d'heures de jours
éventuellement de se re elle il faut
trouver une solution à long terme et au
plus vite car une église
l'irresponsabilité des dirigeants dans
la prise en charge de ce dossier une
quasi absence de décision
gouvernementale
nous vous savons qu'il ya des navires
qui sont au large de résoudre qui
contiennent du mazout équipée du diesel
qui n'attend que le feu vert pour
décharger leurs leur quantité de fioul
mais il faut que la horde du liban où
les crédits nécessaires
il faut ainsi que le gouvernement avec
le paquet et fasse le forcing au plus
vite pour obtenir cette quantité de fuel
car tous les hôpitaux et ça fera taire
au niveau national tous les hôpitaux
risquent de manquer de le fioul et du
carburant étant en danger la vie des
gens est-ce que l'arrêt total du système
de santé au liban est aujourd'hui un
scénario envisagé malheureusement elle
envisagée car les choses évoluent vite
les pénuries aller vite et ça touche
tous les secteurs
vous parliez de bateaux au large de
beyrouth pouvant justement
approvisionner le pays en électricité
quel quelles sont les solutions
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez des
retours par rapport aux dirigeants sur
un éventuel accostage de ces bateaux
nous avons fait à la haine aux
dirigeants au ministre qui s'occupe des
carburants de recours à faire une action
rapide au prix de l'aude elle donnait
les crédits nécessaires que les hôpitaux
puissent télécharger
tit t mais là encore c'est une solution
provisoire il faut réfléchir aux
problèmes de fond et trouver une
solution définitive à ce problème au
liban
est-ce que l'aide internationale
pourrait être aussi envisagées dans le
cas du du liban elle se fait toujours la
bienvenue pour l'instant on devrait
avoir
on devait avoir recours à des
responsabilités vous parliez tout à
l'heure aussi de la fuite du personnel
soignant des infirmiers des médecins
comment vous l'expliquez justement cette
cette fuite du personnel soignant vers
l'étranger etc tu es le haut niveau nous
savons déjà que 2500 médecins qui sont
partis récemment qu'ils veulent tactile
ce c'est l'élite du corps médical
l'alexandra est identique au ski pour le
corps infirmier
la situation économique est
catastrophique l'absence d'anthony la
certitude au liban ont fait partir les
gens et les le pire c'est que des choses
risquent de durer merci beaucoup
nagy abi rached d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin sur arte france rappelle que vous
êtes le chef du service de réanimation
cardiaque et directeur médical hôpital
libanais keita wyss le chu de beyrouth
merci beaucoup